abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhaba ben kendimi bildim bileli Siber
güvenlikle ilgilendim gerçekten başka
hayatımda hiçbir şeyde ilgilenmedim
başka bir şeyden de çok anladığımı
düşünmüyorum Siber güvenlikle de işte
dediğim gibi Kendimi Bildim Bileli bu
alanda çalışmaktayım bugün sizlere Siber
güvenlikle ilgili Hayatımda çok büyük
bir yeri var bunun Hani bir hikayenin
nasıl başladığını benim için Siber
güvenliğe Varan bu domino etkisi
anlatırken tarihsel anlamda da bir
noktada Siber güvenliğin dünyada nasıl
bir hikayeden geçtim sizlere belli
birtakım örneklerle anlatıyor olacağım
bugün Şimdi ben bugün 30 yaşındayım 91
tarihinde doğdum sizi bir onay kadar
geriye götüreceğim 90 yılının Şubat'ı
Çünkü hayatımda Siber güvenliğin böyle
ilk domino yıkılan taşının ilk Aslında
ben doğmadan önce biraz garip bir hikaye
alakalı olduğuna inanıyorum 90 yılında
Benim babam bir tanem
bu işte tomrukların keresteleri
dönüştüğü bir tesiste çalışan orman
mühendisi üniversitelerde 4-5 tane
çocuğun sayı ziyaret ettiği bir etkinlik
düzenleniyor Babam da anlatıyor işte
buradan tomruklar gelmekte işte
bilgisayar destekli sistem var kesiyoruz
bu alıyoruz anlatıyor çocuklardan biri
diyor ki ya peki göğüsler için ne
yapmaktasınız Benim babamın verdiği
cevap çok güzel buhar lıyoruz yani 90
yılında bilgisayarların üzerinde bir
virüs olabileceği algısını olmadığını
trajikomik bir hikayesi Babam da bunu
pek fazla içeride herhalde ki Onay sonra
ben dünyaya geliyorum hayatım Siber
güvenlikle geçiyor Şimdi 90 yılında Hani
virüs dediğiniz anda bilgisayarlarda
virüs olduğunu pek tahlil eden bilgi
birikiminde olmayan Vodafone bir kenara
bırakırsak dünyada ne oluyordu buna
bakalım hep birlikte çoktan arpanet
internete dönüşmüş Aslında o zaman ki
öğrencinin çoktan soruyu sormasına sebep
olan bilgisayar virüsleri Hani çoktan
varlar ve hepimizin bildiği antivirüs
firmaları bu Norton x-y-z isimler
farklılık gösterir o tarihlerde kurulmuş
durumda benim o tarihlerle ilgili ilgimi
çeken en güzel şeylerden bir tanesi de
polimorfik bilgisayar zararlı
yazılımları ile alakalı Tıpkı gerçek
hayattaki virüsler gibi bir Bilgisayara
bulaşan zararlı yazılım başkalaşım
geçiriyor Ama temel özelliklerini
kaybetmiyor verdiği zarar hala aynı ama
onu tanımlayan şeyler de değişkenlik
göstermekte ve böylece sürekli Aslında
farklı bir virüs varmışçasına hayatına
devam eden virüslerin tasarlandığını
gözlemlemekteyiz gerçek hayattaki
virüslerin yaşadığı başkalarının bir
benzerini o yıllardaki zararlı yazılım
geliştiricileri çoktan düşünüp modelleri
bir zamana bakıyoruz akabinde Hani
2000'li yıllara geldiğim zaman benim
böyle işte halayım 11-12 yaşlarında
olduğu zaman ben bilgisayara bağımlı bir
çocuktum hayatım Bilgisayar oynuyor
oynamakla geçti açıkça söylemek
gerekirse ve bu obsesifliği hala kar
yani gelebilmiş değilim hala ben
bilgisayar oyunu oynuyorum Yani kısa bir
hikaye anlatayım Ben de ki komik
onlardan bir tanesidir dosya diye bir
tane oyun var bu oyunda işte kuleye
vurduğumuz zaman kule şey diyorum middle
Tower is Under Attack evde o kadar çok
boyunca oynamışım ki eşimin rüyasında
uyandım yılda bir anda taksiye ayağa
kalktı anları gördüm ben hayatımda
kendimi kontrol etmeye çalışıyorum Bu
konuyla ilgili ama kabullendim bu
özelliği açıkça söylemek gerekirse Şimdi
benim o zamanlarla ilgili Tabii bu kadar
bilgisayar oyunlarına bağımlı olan bir
çocuk şimdi günümüzdeki gibi de hani
bilgisayarı yönetebileceğiniz ebeveyn
kontrol yazılımları da yok yani ve
annemi babamı yapabildiği tek şey
değilse bir parola koymuşlar şimdi o
parola ilginç benim hayatımdaki Siber
güvenlikle ilgili anladım bir diğer
önemli değil taşıdın ait olduğu bir an
Burası Çünkü o bilgisayarın parolası mm
yılında akut 2000'de Şimdi orada Şunu
fark ettim Ben yani 99 yılı depremi
olmuş durumda Bu depremde hali maalesef
hayatını kaybetmiş insanlar var ve akut
arama kurtarma operasyonları
gerçekleştiriyor yıl mm o adamın parola
e Okul mm oluyor işte yani O zaman
anlamıştım ki İnsanların hayatında
değerli olan ne varsa kıymetli Önemli
olan ne var ise bu bir şekilde
parolaların da yer edilmekte günümüzde
hala daha bu aynıdır ki o zamanlarda
benim ilk e-posta Parol anda Ayşe Bir de
Ayşe ilkokulda aşık olduğu kızın adı
Yani önemli Neyse abi sen bunu paralı mı
içerisinde belirliyorsun ister istemez
Peki oyunlarda ne oldu dünyada dersek
benim Benim de mağdurlarından biri
olduğu bir Ay Lav Yu virüsü vardı
hatırlayanlar varsa el kaldırırsa çok
sevinirim yani Ay Lav Yu virüsü o
dönemlerde çok kısa bir sürede 10 milyon
bilgisayar bulaşmış bir bilgisayar
zararlı yazılımı bir e-posta geliyor
size seni seviyorum diye sana bir aşk
mektubu var tadına bile posta geliyor
e-postanın içeriğinde tıkladığınız zaman
içeriğindeki ekli dosya tıkladığınız
zaman zararlı yazılım aynı e-postayı
sizin eposta adresleri kimlerle
konuştuğu kız bunları kendisi tekrardan
çoğaltarak göndermekte çok kısa bir
sürede o en son Bilgisayara bulaşan bir
zararlı yazılımdan bahsediyoruz benim
için bir diğer domino taşıdı bu olmuştu
insanlar Merak ettiği şeye tıklar
dijital dünya Gerçekten böyle Bugün 21
21 yılındayız devlet destekli hacker
gruplarının ev İleri düzey Belki de
organize ettikleri Siber saldırıların
içinde hala daha bir insan ve insanın
bir şekilde merak ettirmesini sağlayacak
bir hikaye bulunuyor ya Gerçekten bu
zincirin en zayıf halkalarından bir
tanesi gerçekten hala daha insan faktörü
bunun üzerine tekrardan Hani bu
konuşmanın sonlarını tekrardan
bahsediyor olacağım Bazı örneklerden
şimdi bu kadar ilgili olan Hani bir
insan olarak ben artık şu soruları sordu
mu hatırlıyorum ya Bir web sitesine
giriyorsunuz resim çıkıyor ya Bu web
sitesi nasıl internet dediği şey ne
nasıl çalışıyor Bunlar Ben websitesi
yapabilir miyim diye çok ahmakça sorular
Bu soruların peşine Bilgisayardan da
başka obsesifliği olmayan bir insan
olarak damlaların peşine düştüm ve ve
Öyle de böyle bir ders Ben hatırlıyorum
yayınladım okula gidiyorum geliyorum
bilgisayar açıyorum işte ulaşmakta
Üzerinde Bir gün okuldan geldim
unutamadığım bir an benim için
hayatımdaki çok gerçekten kırılma
noktalarından biri ile benim için Çünkü
okuldan eve geldim kafamda bir tane
destesi eklemek istedim özellik fikri
var destesini ziyaretçi sayacı koyacağım
Hani herkesi girdikçe artacak 17 yazıyor
16'sı benim zaten web sitesinde bu
özelliği koymak için hepsini açtım bakır
bakarken Şok oldum bir alma çünkü
websitesi değişmiştir yani Yare bakıyor
Yukarıdaki linke bakıyorum benim nefis
tam içeriğine bakıyorum alevler
kurukafalar maaşı takip eden yanan
baloncuklar işte küfürler yazıyor bir
şeyler ve ben Aklımda iki tane soruyu o
anda hissettim hala daha bu iki soruyu
unutmadım bir bu insanlar kimi bunu
nasıl yaptılar Çünkü artık Kompleksi
paralı kullanıyordum artık Ayşe yerine A
yerine ete yerine 3 sonra da bir 337
günden falan koyalım kompleks bir para
olan vardı benim karmaşık daha fazla var
ama biz parkta ortada web sitesi artık
ele geçirilmişti ikinci sorusu şuydu bu
baloncukları Nasıl yaptınız Mouse'lu
takip eden baloncuk Alevli Baloncuk
nasıl yapılıyor ben bu iki sorunun
peşine düştüm hayatımdaki bir diğer
domino taşının diğerini tetiklediği Ama
bu vaka olmuştu Çünkü o günden beri ben
hayatımda sadece Siber güvenlikle
ilgilendim Çok ilgimi çekmiş bir konuydu
şimdi o zaman ki tarihi yani o dönemin
internetinde ne olduğuna bakalım
dünyasında ne olduğuna Bakın şimdi ben
Aptalca bir takım bilgiler öğrenme
çabasında bir insanken dünyada artık
devletlerin Siber güvenliği defansif
değil ofansif taraftada kullanmaya
başladı örnekleri görmeye başladık
İran'ın nükleer santrallerine
düzenlenmiş Sabotaj etmek üzere özel
geliştirilmiş zararlı yazılımları
ispatları görmeye başladı Bir taraftan
bahsediyoruz günümüzde bir devlet başka
bir devletin herhangi bir şey yapmak
istediğinizde işte sallıyorum farazi
örnek Asker gönderir savaş çıkarsa bunu
haberlerde görürsün Isparta ortadadır
ama dijital dünya için Eve geldiğinde
her şey artık inkar edilebilir bir
noktaya geliyor aramızda Siber
saldırıların varlığını kimler inanıyor
el kaldırabilir mi mi Hemen hemen
herkese görüyorum şu anda Peki kaç kişi
Siber saldırı gördüm
ama ben maalesef diyebilirim kendi adıma
Herşey görmediğimiz bir şey varlığına
inanıyoruz ve her şey gerçekten sahte
yapılabilir bir dünya olduğunu da bir
noktada unutmamamız gerekiyor ve bu
gerçekten artık ülkeler içinde son
derece
kullanılabilir bir dünya olduğu ortaya
çıkmıştı ve 2007 yılında Özellikle bu
işte stuxnet zararlı yazılımın dan
bahsediyorum sizlere İran'ın yaşadığı
böyle bir durumla karşılaşmış olduk
Benim bu Siber güvenlik dünyasına olan
aşkım Günün Sonunda beni Sakarya
Üniversitesi bilgisayar mühendisliği
sırasına kadar getirdi bu bölümü yazdım
burayı kazandım zaten 10 yıldır Hani
orayı kazanana kadar onyıldız
bilgisayarda bu dünyaya harcamış bir
insan olarak merakın bu yöndeydi şimdi
diğer benim için kırılma noktalarından
bir tanesi de hani ilginç Benim için
özel bir İlginç olan bir diğer Anılar
üniversitede Ben bir şekilde kendimi
Sakarya Üniversitesi'nin Bilgi İşlem
Daire Başkanlığı içerisinde İnik sistem
yönetimi adı verilen bu çalışan bir
öğrenci olarak buldum üniversite bir
sınıfın işte sonlarına doğru 2 dönemde
Hatta büyük ihtimalle O da ne okulda bir
etkinlik organize edildi etkinlik
girişimcilik üzerine konuşmacılardan bir
tanesini Hadi Sabancı bizde bilgi
işlemde bu konuşmayı canlı yayınla
sistemlerin başında duruyor gecikme var
mı vesaire diye bakmak dayız konuşmasını
unutmadığım bir diğer bir cümlesi var
Ali beyin üniversite rektöründen
bahsediyordu rektörün adıda Mehmet dedi
Dedi ki şöyle bir cümlesi var Ben
Rektörlüğü çok seviyorum Hani Mehmet
Bey'i girişimcilikte Bazen hayatta doğru
zamanda doğru yerde hızlı davranmakla
alakalıdır O yüzden on numara mehmet.com
u alıp Bugün şu anda Buraya gelen kişi
bin lira vereceğim ben de bir cümle
çıktı ya Ben dedim ki alalım hani güzel
bin lira İyi para Ben de laf almak
istiyorum açıkçası o zaman yani hani
aradım Babama dedim ki kredi kartı
bilgilerini lazım Ne için domain
alacağım bıkmadın mı çocukluğundan beri
domain alıyorsun yeter falan git geldik
net bir şekilde ben kredi kartını aldım
ve bu da mayın alımını gerçekleştirdim
gittim o o o hani okulda saçlarını bir
lanet bir 15 binası yanında yokuş vardı
yok işten koşarak aşağı etkinlik alanına
gittim günün sonunda şöyle bir fotoğraf
Hayal edin aklınızda sağında üniversite
Rektörü solumda Ali Sabancı benim elimde
bin lira bir fotoğrafım var
ve 1500 kişide izliyor böyle bir ana ve
belki de şansa gerçekten sahip olduğum
ama benim için bu hikaye de değişen
noktası nasıl oldu o bin lira ile
kapağını fırsatım oldu ve o Laptop ile
Can yıldızlı kolye kuzen isimli iki tane
arkadaşımla yıllardır hayalini kurduğum
uzun süredir üzere düşündüğümüz bir konu
vardı saldırıları yaşanmadan önce nasıl
tespit edebiliriz Bir yazılım ile bu
yazılımı yazmayı o bilgisayarla başladık
Ve bugün hala prograf tadında bir sigara
firmasını kurucu ortağı Üçümüzde ve o
laptopla bugünkü o teknoloji
geliştirmeye başladığımız andı benim
için hayattaki Siber güvenlik Severim De
ki bir diğer domino taşı da bu olmuştu
Ali Sabancı Bey de hani bu şimdilik
ilgili bir etkinlikte farkında olmadan
bizim firmamızın bir ilk yatırımcısı
oldu diyebilirim yani o bin liralık bir
ödülle şimdi
o zamanların içerisinden Tüm bu serüveni
hep birlikte sizlere anlatmaya çalıştım
ben Günün Sonunda şu ya günümüzde
geldiğimiz zaman şunu farketmek
gerekiyor dijital dünyanın getirdiği bir
risk var ve Siber saldırılar var herkes
buna da mutabık herkes böyle bir riskin
var olduğunda bilmekte ama bence
birazcık farklı bir açıdan bakmaya de
ihtiyacımız var Evet yani kompleks
paralı kullanmak işin içerisinde önemli
ama hani günün sonunda saldırganlar her
zaman insanın doğasındaki bir noktayı
kullanmakta var Bu hep böyle oldu
anlattığım hikayeleri içerisindeki
örneklerde de var Şimdi bunu bir anlamak
gerekiyor işin temelinde yani pandemi de
örnek verebilirim size pandemi döneminde
Hani hepimizin eve kapandı hepimizin
daha fazla internet kaynaklarını
kullandığı dönemde cinsel ve internet
servis sağlayıcılığı dediler İyi bari
Bedavadan ekstralı internet verelim
herkes evinde ve ciddi bir kullanım var
şimdi hayatta ne yaşanırsa saldırganlar
bunu her zaman bir silah olarak
kullanmaktan var böyle bir ortamı
gördükleri an itibariyle bu kampanyalı
Jason firmaları çıktı an itibariyle biz
şunu gördük pandemi döneminde Facebook
Google gibi büyük platform larda
reklamlar sahte reklamlar 20gb bedava
internet reklamı karşınıza çıkıyor Bir
de artık teknoloji öyle bir noktaya
gelmiş ki hedeflediğiniz grubu 35 40 ve
seçebiliyorsunuz 50 yaş üstünde olsun
işte şu alanda bir ilgi duymuş kişilere
sürekli mı çıkart Reklamın içerisinde
sahte bir uygulama Siz uygulama
indirdiğin zaman Telefonunuzda
bankacılıkla ilgili işlem yapmak
istediğiniz an bu zararlı yazılım
devreye giriyor ve bankanızdan para
dışarıya başka bir hesaba çıkmış oluyor
yani biz bir şeyler görüyoruz hani görüp
bakıyoruz ve Evet Hani hayatta
gördüğümüz o anda Önemli olan şeylere de
bu o aşıyor günün sonunda bu yüzden
Güven duyuyoruz şimdi buradaki en önemli
konu Güven kelimesi Siber güvenliğin
başındaki sivri unutun Güven kelimesine
bakalım hep birlikte biz var
olduğumuzdan beri en önemli konu en iç
günümüz güvenliktir yani Birisi vurmak
istediğinizde Vücudun ve ses bile
geliştirmiştir bunun için Çünkü güvende
olmak istersiniz bundan Hani belki de
bin yıl önce size ait olan bir elinizde
elma var Bunu bir almak istediğinizde
vermezseniz Hani gücü yetip kafanıza
vurup olabilirse alır Ama siz gene size
ait olan şeyi sahipliğini aidiyetini
kendiniz de hissedersiniz bu iş günü
değişmedi değişmeyecek de ama Siber
dünyanın kuralları bu iş günü için çok
uygulanabilir bir dünya olmuyor bakış
açımızı bir noktada değiştirme
ihtiyacımız var Bugün bir araba
aldığınız zaman bu arabaya gelir sigorta
yaptırıyorsun Çünkü arabanın başına bir
şey gelebilir ve size ait olan bir şey
zarar görebilir O yüzden bu kompanze
etmek için gidip sigorta yaptırmak
tasını zeval eve gidip bunun işte
baskını yaptırmak dayız paramız var yedi
Bunu bankaya koyuyoruz Çünkü neden
Güvenilir bir mercie günün sonunda Yani
biz güvenlikle ilgili hususlar ımıza
içgüdüsel olarak kendimiz tek başımıza
yetinmeyip daha üst mecrada bir şeyden
destekli hizmet almaya ilmindeyiz Lakin
konu Siber güvenliğe geldiği zaman bu iş
Maalesef bu düzlemde bu şekilde
yıllardır alıştığımız düzlemde
yaşanmıyor bugün sosyal medyada Twitter
hepimizin kullandığı bildiği birşey
Twitter'da hani İşte doğrulanmış
hesaplar görüyorsunuz yani Donald
trump'ın bizim ülkemizden herkesin
birçok Aslında Artık neredeyse siyasetin
halka ulaştığı bir yazılı metin ve ortam
olmuş bu kadar kritik bir yapıda
insanların demetlerinin doğruluğuna
gördüğümüz şeylerden erişim sağlıyoruz
bundan 3-4 ay kadar önce Twitter'da
yaşanan Sibel vakaya hatırlayanlar var
mıdır bilmiyorum Twitter'da saldırganlar
Twitter'da istedikleri hesaptan
istedikleri Tweety Ata bilecekleri bir
noktaya gel ama bunu yaparken de hani
İşin komik tarafı demeyeyim de ilginç
tarafı şu bunu 18 yaşında İngiltere
biten çocuk yapıyor çivi tırda çalışan
ve destek ekibindeki insanların
limitinden gelip sosyal mavisi
kandırıyor ve gidip bunun üzerine de
niye olsam sana portal verir bu olaylar
böyle yaşandı diye bu çocuğun Hani
Enişte bu gıcık bakabilir misiniz
hepimizin farkında mıyız hani bu adamlar
ne yaptı derseniz bu tür işte Donald
trump'ın hesabından alınmazken
hesabından bir topluluğa destek oluyoruz
hiçbir Bitcoin adresi yayınladılar bu
bitkinin adresine gönderdim falan iki
katına aynı dedesi geri göndereceğiz
dedi 8 saatte 150 bin dolar birlikte o
hesapta ama bu birazcık Tabii ki de hani
gerçek riski ortaya çıkaran bir şey
değil Sizlerden istediğim kendinize bu
güce sahip bir pozisyona koyun
Twitter'da istediğiniz kişinin
hesabından istediğiniz Tweety
atabileceğiniz bir noktada olduğunuzu
hissedin arkadaşlar ne yapardınız
gerçekten kötüdür bu çalışın Savaş bile
çıkılabilecek kadar önemli bir nokta
burası yanlış beyanlar yapılabilecek
kadar ya ekonomi etkileyebilecek şeylere
kadar tek kabul edebiliyor ama hani
gerisin geri temel bir noktaya dönmek
gerekirse işin içerisinde Hani
gördüğümüz şeylerin doğruluğu buna güven
Algoritma mızı bakış açımızı
değiştirmemiz bir ihtiyaç yan 1990
yılındaki bir virüsü buharlaşarak
çözemiyor duk günümüzde de keşke elimde
öyle buhar olsa da hani başıma bir bela
geldiğinde buharlaşıp çözebiliyor olsam
ama maalesef bu bu şekilde yaşanmıyor
Çok teşekkür ederim dinlediğiniz için
Çok sağ olun
[Alkış]